[Música]
[Aplausos]
há cinco anos atrás do dia que embarquei
para boston onde fiz minha graduação é
dormir disse renan
desenvolva suas asas para que possa
alcançar vôos sempre maiores
mas não deixa de cuidar das suas raízes
para que você nunca se esqueça da onde
veio a crise são gonçalo terra de
grandes talentos como o eterno palhaço
carequinha veneza junho claudinho e
buchecha e tantos outros
gosto de representar como carioca da
clara seu filho e sobrinho de
professores que tive minha vida
transformada através da educação
cresci no bairro mutuá em são gonçalo
onde brincadeira diversão era ficar na
rua jogando bolinha de gude pedindo a
bola que caiu na casa do vizinho
jogando o peão e tantas outras coisas
uma infância - tecnológica e mais
analógica quando tinha dez anos algo
muito importante aconteceu na minha vida
um tio e disse que deveria tentar
estudar no colégio militar do rio de
janeiro me dizendo que era uma escola
pública de qualidade que aquilo poderia
ser muito importante para minha vida
representou diversos argumentos para
tentar convencer mas só conseguiu quando
me disse que aprova o total da prova
seria no maracanã
dentro do maracanã o estádio do flamengo
algo que fui fiz a prova e não passei
então eu fiquei matemática
logo uma matéria favorita e se hoje o
primeiro impossível da minha vida
estudava na escola pública de qualidade
pensei logo que seria pra mim acho que o
apoio da minha família estudei bastante
para voltar ao maracanã e desta vez
marcar um golaço
a cabeça não aceita no colégio militar
onde estudei do 6º ano do ensino
fundamental até o 3º ano do ensino médio
do colégio foi muito mais do que motivo
disso acabou se tornando a segunda casa
lá tive acesso a uma educação
diferenciada que é também da sala de
aula e permitindo participar de vários
esportes fazer o inter e científicas
matemática química e redação história
que tivesse fazer
e principalmente ensinou a pensar
coletivamente nessa pegada através de um
professor
eu conheci uma organização chamada
solidariedade em marcha os o mar que faz
uma série de atividades sociais no
complexo do vinde que fica localizado na
zona norte do rio de janeiro
fiquei encantado com aquela experiência
de trabalho social e decidir junto com o
prêmio começar um curso comunitário de
21 somar inglês em que dava aula de
inglês para crianças da comunidade todos
os sábados de manhã o complexo lynch
fica localizado na estrada
grajaú-jacarepaguá ao redor dessa
estrada
eu peguei essa estrada diversas vezes
ela conecta zona norte do rio
a zona oeste sem problema pra frente eu
sempre tinha uma direção
a partir do momento que eu comecei a
trabalhar com somar eu comecei a olhar
para os lados
eu sabia onde era capela para saber onde
a associação de moradores
eu sabia que era boca de fumo eu sabia
da casa da dona joana que aquilo me fez
perceber o complexo somente é um rio de
janeiro
a partir dessa experiência eu percebi
que eu queria trabalhar com pessoas para
pessoas
e por pessoas nessa mesma época que ouvi
dizer de uma menina diz o ons ao a
flávia que também estudava no colégio
evitar que eu tinha sido aceite round e
aquilo foi um boom na minha vida como
ter alguém poderia se formava seu médio
e diretos da em harvard
pensei que fosse uma gênia uma exceção e
que aquilo fosse possível na vida real
então alguém tão próximo do meu contexto
e aí o segundo é impossível que não
seria possível estudar na escola fora
tão conceituada custos eram caras pra
você tentar esse processo não tinha
informações nem moral para isso mas no
ano seguinte
outros brasileiros alguns também de
escola pública for aceito três grandes
adversidades
eu comecei a ter um facto talvez assim
possível era tão impossível assim quando
parei pra perceber o custo disso também
tomei um susto mas descobriu
organizações que ajudava jovens que não
tinham condições de aplicar para essa
tendência
aqui com bolsa de estudo e como teoria e
decidir entrar nesse processo
depois de um nova de muito estudo a
cabeça você
em algumas universidades incluindo
princeton iei o colômbia e havard onde a
partir de agosto de 2013 eu comecei a
estudar com bolsa integral
economia e ciências políticas rafa de
uma grande revolução na minha vida
lá eu tive aula com professores
fenomenais conhecer ao mundo as pessoas
de mais de 80 países e conhecer muito
mais do mundo e diferentes culturas e
nessa experiência comecei a refletir
muito sobre o que eu poderia fazer para
retribuir para a sociedade tudo que eu
tinha recebido de ajuda e todas as
oportunidades que acabaram acontecendo
na minha vida
com essa motivação não confundir com
dois amigos
o formigueiro o primeiro site de
financiamento coletivo no brasil
totalmente voltado para a educação
a idéia é muito simples a gente escolhia
projetos que precisavam de ajuda com
pessoas que queriam ajudar essas
iniciativas e acompanhá-las fazendo
assim um namoro ou tiveram em casamento
e social tivesse impacto tão relevante
só ajudava os projetos de baixa baixo
custo rápida execução elevado impacto
social local
um dos projetos que chamou mais atenção
veio do município de quixelô no interior
do ceará
coordenado pelo gilberto o devedor do
projeto e professor de educação física
que pensam dessa escolinha de futebol
condicionada à leitura de livros só
podia fazer parte da escolinha quem vê
se uma certa quantidade de livros por
mês
ele jogava sem trazem sem chuteiras em
nenhum material básico para se ter um
projeto acontecendo então o gilberto
decidiu escrever esse projeto não for
menino pedindo mil trezentos e noventa
reais para comprar materiais esportivos
livros que conseguiu em poucas semanas
apesar do sucesso do formigueiro foi
ficando cada vez mais claro para mim que
num país com mais de 200 milhões de
pessoas e 40 milhões de alunos na
educação básica a gente só conseguiria
mudar a educação de fato a gente também
trabalhasse com política
públicas com isso em mente comecei a
trabalhar no começo de 2014
um grupo de jovens muito inspiradores
pensando em algum produto ou serviço que
a gente pudesse trazer juventude de
volta pra pensar os principais temas de
educação deste país
mas antes de tudo seria necessário
entender qual era o cenário educacional
e para isso decidimos fazer algumas
dessas entrevistas
essas dez entrevistas acabaram virando
sempre quatro entrevistas com a
secretária de educação que
representantes de fundação
líderes de sindicato professores
ex-ministros diversas pessoas e daí
surgiu do manifesto mapa do buraco
o manifesto suprapartidário que mapeou
os principais buracos e gargalos da
educação brasileira e apontou alguns
casos de sucesso que existe no nosso
país como sobral ceará que foz do iguaçu
no paraná
o mapa do buraco tem um impacto muito
grande nas eleições de 2014 e motivado
por isso criamos o movimento mato e
ducação para permitir que novas
iniciativas com o mapa do buraco fosse
impossível movimento que quer fazer da
educação ponto prioritário neste país
através do protagonismo jovem temos hoje
vontade em todos os estados do país que
trabalham com conferências debates
workshops e eventos que mobilizam a
sociedade é o tema de educação por
exemplo
em agosto de 2007 tivemos a segunda
conferência do mapa que reuniu 250
jovens de vários cantos do país para
falarem sobre seus projetos educacionais
e temas de relevância nacional
uma das pessoas foi à arena dos santos
uma índia da etnia ou à piscina do
estado de roraima
mais especificamente na cidade de
trujillo que fica a 65 quilômetros de
boa vista
o iene foi até são paulo para
compartilhar a importância de termos uma
educação de qualidade para os povos
indígenas ea representatividade
histórica que também seria importante
dos seus povos
e nessa pegada surgiu certa forma
internamente o terceiro é possível na
minha média trabalhar para a educação
brasileira fosse modelo
mundial o mapa continuou seu trabalho
nessa frente mas ainda falta muito
interesse e vontade política para que
isso possa acontecer com essa indignação
essa inquietação junto compartilhado de
outros amigos
vou fazer um novo movimento o acredita
movimento de renovação política que som
é congresso com a cara do brasil
uma gravação de princípios práticas e
pessoas hoje não acredita
estamos presente em 15 estados somos
mais de dois mil voluntários que
acredito que é possível ter um país mais
justo desenvolvido e ético e nessa busca
de desconstruir impossíveis
chegou a hora de desenvolver as asas de
cuidar das raízes
ao mesmo tempo no mesmo lugar para isso
decidiu voltar para o brasil assim que
me formei em dezembro de 2017 para
continuar meu trabalho como empreendedor
social que ativista tema educação
estava na hora que voltar pra casa e
fazer acontecer daqui
apesar dos nossos problemas que precisam
ser enfrentados e reconhecidos com
coragem eu confio decoração que o brasil
tem jeito
e acredito que é um potencial e força da
minha ajuda da minha geração
vamos fazer esse país de vez o país do
presente e que o caminho para isso é
através de uma educação de qualidade
para todos os brasileiros e todas as
brasileiras e esse terceiro é possível
que fazer da educação um modelo mundial
a educação brasileira mas mundial ainda
está em curso e continuar por algum
tempo mas eu tenho a convicção de que
essa é a causa da minha vida de que mais
importante do que definir o que queremos
ser é definir o que queremos mudar
e pra mim a resposta é a educação
brasileira
até porque como dizia o poeta chorão do
charlie brown júnior para quem tem
pensamento forte é impossível é só
questão de opinião muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]